Okay, folks. We have to talk about who
we think should be the next attorney
general of the United States to replace
attorney general Pam Body. There's some
people that I really do not think should
take that job and we do not want in that
job. And I'm going to explain my views,
why I think that's the case, because
there's a lot of people that may
disagree with what I have to say. Uh,
but I want you to understand why I think
the people that I identify in this video
are no go zones if you support the right
to keep him bear arms. And I'm gonna
identify a couple people that you might
find interesting as prospects to be the
next attorney general of the United
States, including that's right, Supreme
Court Justice Samo and Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas. Hear me out
when we come right back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box, a proud American gun owner,
constitutional attorney, member of the
United States Supreme Court Barn, and
I'm proud to say the top voice the
second amendment in America. Thank you.
2025 and 2026 Gundy's awards. All right,
folks. We all know that Attorney General
Pam Bondi is no longer the attorney
general of the United States. There are
many people in the Second Amendment
community are very happy about this and
maybe they're right to be happy. Maybe
it's going to turn out this is a big
mistake. I'm hope I'm hopeful things
will work out for the best. Now, just
before I talk about who I think we
should definitely not want to be the
attorney general of the United States
next and who maybe we want to be the
next attorney general of the United
States, I want to just give you briefly
my view of the lay of the land for the
last year plus. Here's my bottom line
when it comes to Attorney General Pam
Bondi. I want to be very clear about
this. Pam Bondi could have done a better
job as the attorney general when it
comes to our second amendment rights.
However, listen carefully. This is what
makes you the smartest person in the
room. Pam Bondi was not the cause of the
problems we faced when it came to our
second amendment rights as I see it. She
did not cause the problem. Listen
carefully what I'm saying. Okay.
However, Attorney General Pam Body did
not take appropriate steps in my opinion
to stop bad decisions that were made by
other people at the Department of
Justice. Hear what I just said. Pam
Bonnie was not the cause of the mistakes
and in my view mistaken strategies
associated with the Second Amendment
when it came to the Department of
Justice. But she did not intercede and
stop it because I'm not sure she
understood that that was going on and
did not understand the full complexity
of what was happening.
My concern is that although Harmy Dylan
at as the head of civil rights has done
a fantastic job with that second
amendment unit, she has argued f in a
fantastic way in the US court of appeals
for the seventh circuit on behalf of the
second amendment and in a quote unquote
assault weapon ban case, magazine ban
case. There's been excellent amikas
briefs filed on behalf of the second
amendment. Applaud the DOJ for that.
They have sued DC for the so-called ban
on large capacity magazines and the ban
on AR-15s and the like. They have sued
licensing divisions in various parts of
America, including California, for being
too slow and not good enough. They've
set up a second amendment task force, a
second amendment unit within the
Department of Justice. This is
unprecedented. Unprecedented. And we
should applaud the work of the
Department of Justice, Pam Bonnie and
Harmony Dylan, 100% for what they've
done. They are by far, period,
historically accurate, the best Second
Amendment Department of Justice we've
ever seen. Okay. Now, with that said,
there are certain things that they did
in my view they should have done
differently. For example, pushing the US
versus Hmani case to the Supreme Court,
which was a terrible set of facts.
Why would the solicister general's
office push the Hermmani case with a guy
that was allegedly a drug dealer? He
admitted using cocaine. He admitted to
using marijuana and you're going to use
that as your precedent setting case for
18 USC 922G cases when you support the
second amendment instead of like a good
case like Brian Range. It was a very
sympathetic back pattern or pushing
young adult cases, the Ree case out of
the fifth circuit for 18, 19, and 20
years to finally have full-blown Second
Amendment rights. No, it's my view and I
don't have inside knowledge on this, but
I just have a feel for this. I find it
very difficult to believe that Pam
Bonnie had any real role in any of that
in terms of recommending it. Therefore,
who did it? Who did it? And it is my
guess without I'm speculating a little
bit here. I'm disclosing right now. I'm
speculating a little bit, but I have a
feel for this as to how this works at
the Department of Justice. Okay. I have
a strong suspicion
that the reason why we're seeing a
refusal to enter favorable consent
decrees in favor of the second amendment
around the country with second amendment
advocacy groups like gun owners of
America, second amendment foundation,
firearms policy coalition and so on.
Okay. I have a feeling the reason why
the DOJ is not doing those sorts of
things. Why DOJ is pushing the wrong
cases to the Supreme Court in the firm
of Hammani. why they are not seek
concern in cases on good fact patterns
like range and Ree and others as to why
they are messing around with the scope
of the remedy by arguing that if you're
not a member on the day the lawsuits
filed and or the day the judgments
entered then you cannot benefit from
being a beneficiary or a member of an
organization which is clearly against
all Supreme Court president going back
decades. I have a I am guessing the
reason why this is occurring is probably
because of some combination of the
solicitor general's office led by John
Sauer and the number two person at the
Department of Justice Todd Blanch. So
with that said, the two people that
should not be and I do not want to see
as the head of the Department of
Justice, and it's not because they're
bad lawyers, it's not because they're
bad people, it's not because they're
problem children or anything like that.
It's just I do not think if you support
the second amendment, you want Todd
Blanch or John Sauer or anyone from that
solicitor general's office to be the
next attorney general of the United
States. I think that would be a mistake
because I believe and this is again
based on supposition and suspicion but I
think it's sort of wellfounded feel for
the dynamic here that these arguments
these refusal to res to to resolve
certain matters in favor of the second
amendment is probably coming in some
combination from Todd Blanch the number
two person in the department of justice
now the interim attorney general from
the solicitor general's office and John
Sauer and or career attorney attorneys
at the Department of Justice.
This is the cause of our issues to date.
And again, I'm not taking away the great
work in favor of the Second Amendment,
which overall has been fantastic and I'm
very supportive of this Department of
Justice, okay?
I'm simply saying if you want to improve
at the margins, if you want incremental
improvements in favor of the Second
Amendment, better cases being pushed to
the Supreme Court, not pushing stupid
cases to the Supreme Court that have the
potential to set bad precedent because
bad facts make bad law. And we know that
Justice Alto and Justice Roberts don't
like drug cases. They don't like
druggies. Everyone knows this. They're
law and order guys. And that's not
necessarily a bad thing, but don't push
a Second Amendment case with those sorts
of fact patterns to the court. If you
know they don't like it, avoid that.
Just ple it out. Settle it. Get rid of
it. Don't don't charge the person.
Whatever it is, don't bring bad cases to
the Supreme Court. And there's a lot of
ways to avoid that. Okay? So, no Todd
Blanch in my view, no John Sour, no one
from the Solicitor General's office,
none of those people should be the next
attorney general of the United States.
Again, I'm not beating up Todd Blanch,
who did an excellent job for Donald
Trump. He's done a lot of great stuff.
I'm not here beating him up. I'm just
saying in terms of this particular
position of being the attorney general
of the United States, Todd Blanch, who's
a former successful federal prosecutor
in the United States uh in the United
States Attorney's Office for the
Southern District of New York, an
extremely prestigious pro prosecutor's
office. The Southern District of New
York's US Attorney's Office is probably
the most prestigious prosecutor's office
in the world. And by the way, I worked
there for six months. I've been there. I
went through the the background checks.
I was there. I've worked in the Southern
District. I know it. I get it. Okay. I
didn't want a career there. I had a
different way. I didn't really want to
do it. But nevertheless, I get it. But
it's very much full of careers, people
that want to use the credential of the
being at the US attorney's office in the
southern district of New York in lower
Manhattan is a very prestigious
credential. A lot of people go there to
basically build their resume up and go
make a lot of money in the private
sector. Okay, nothing wrong with that.
But they're full of careerists. They're
full of law and order types. They're not
full of Make America Great Again
supporters when it comes to the Second
Amendment. They may not hate the Second
Amendment, but I don't think they're
going to go as far as we in the
community want. So again, no Todd
Blanch, no one from the SG's office, no
career uh DOJ person, no one like that.
Okay, that's category one in my opinion.
I could be totally wrong on this.
History could prove me completely wrong,
but that's how I see it right now and
why I see it that way. Okay, nothing
against these people, but I don't think
they're the right person for this job at
this time. I'm not saying we should fire
Todd Blanch or John Sour. No, I don't
think that at all. I just don't think
they should be elevated to be the
attorney general of the United States.
That's all I'm saying and that's why I
believe it. Okay, now let's talk about
someone who I love, Harmy Dylan. We all
love Harmy Dylan. She 100% should
absolutely not be the attorney general
of the United States. Okay. It would be
a terrible loss to the second amendment
movement and to America to lose that
force of nature Har Dylan to pull her
out of being the head of the civil
rights division where she is doing
groundbreaking presidential changes in
that office and pull her out to make her
the attorney general of the United
States where she will be entirely
distracted with nonsense. She will be
distracted by death penalty cases. She
will be distracted by going before
Congress to testify about the Department
of Justice budgets. She will have to
talk about sentencing guidelines. She
will have to manage, you know, the
dozens and dozens of US attorneys
offices across the country and deal with
all that nonsense. We do not want
Harmony dealing do doing anything else
but going on TV talking about civil
rights, talking about voting rights,
talking about voting integrity, talking
about uh stopping DEI, stopping race
discrimination, stopping religious
discrimination, and protecting our
Second Amendment rights. We do not want
anyone to replace Harmony Dylan as the
head of the civil rights division at the
DOJ. That would be a terrible loss. Not
because they don't have great people
there, but she obviously is a force of
nature. And if you pull her out of this
position, in my opinion, it would be
analogous to a a company that has a
sales force. Okay? You know how it
works. I've been in business a long
time. I was on Wall Street. I'm very
good when it comes to business and all
that good stuff. And the reality is
this. It is often the case. Your best
salesman, your best salesperson
is not the right person to be the sales
manager. See what I'm saying? Harmy
Dylan is a fantastic salesperson. And I
mean that metaphorically, of course,
right? She's fantastic at the job she's
in. Do not move her. Not because she
would not be a good attorney general.
She would be an excellent attorney
general of the United States. She would
be great at the job, but it would be a
total waste of her skill set and a total
waste of what she's doing at the Civil
Rights Division of the Department of
Justice, which has historically been a
cesspool. If you support America, if you
support meritocracy, if you support
voter integrity, if you support the
Second Amendment, it is a cesspool at
the at the Civil Rights Division of the
Department of Justice. And Harmy Dylan
is cleaning out the crap and fixing it.
We do not want her in the middle of this
mission to be pulled off the job. It
would be terrible to lose her. Even
though she'd be great as the attorney
general of the United States, she is not
the person to do it because we cannot
afford, in my opinion, in the Second
Amendment community, from the point of
view of the Second Amendment committee
or the community, I should say, from the
Second Amendment community, we cannot
afford for Harmy Dylan to move from the
position she's in now. She is far too
important in that role. She should not
become the attorney general of the
United States. Not because she's not
qualified, but because we need her to
keep doing what she's doing. And if we
have a president Vance or President
Rubio, yes, then we can have a
conversation about elevating uh Harmy
Dylan to the attorney general of the
United States, that might be perfect,
but not now. The timing is not right for
America or the Second Amendment movement
for Harmy Dylan to make that move in my
opinion. Okay. Now, with that said,
there's been a lot of talk about someone
who I'm sort of leaning towards
supporting and that is Lee Zeldon. Now,
Lee Zeldon is a former congressman from
New York and he has kicked butt. Two
points I want to make. First of all, he
has kicked butt as the head of the EPA.
He has gotten rid of, and this is hugely
important, he destroyed the so-called
endangerment finding. Now, if you want
to Google endangerment finding, it's an
absurd thing by the lefties and the deep
state bureaucrats to essentially
globally, if you will, declare CO2. Oh,
that would be the things we exhale and
the trees breathe in. You know that sort
of process there was it that you know
what I'm saying? That whole process of
uh of exhaling uh yes that greenhouse
gases that process of CO2 was declared a
danger to the world. Absurd. And we
don't need to get into those debates. We
can do the science if you feel the need
to do it at some point. But the reality
is that Lee Zelden stood up to the deep
state. He stood up to the bureaucrats at
the EPA, which of course is another
cesspool. When it comes to if you love
America, it's a cesspool. And if you
love capitalism and free markets and
freedom and money and property, it's a
cesspool. As far as I'm concerned, the
whole EPA, that's my opinion. You can
disagree if you want, but anyway, Leon
stood up the deep state and shut it down
by getting rid of the endangerment fine.
He might be the perfect person, although
I hate to lose him at the EPA. uh it
might be a fair trade for him to give up
the EPA role and become the next
attorney general of the and by the way
he does have an A rating from the NRA.
He supports the right to carry. Uh he
opposes assault weapon bans. Uh he was
good on Operation Chokepoint. He does
not want semi-automatic rifle bans. All
these things he's good on all the
issues. So when it comes to being good
on the Second Amendment, I don't think
there's any issue that you're not going
to find a you're going to find an
excellent person in Lee Zelden. I don't
think there's any debate in that. I
think if you look at his uh grades, if
you look at his votes, if you look at
his speeches and whatnot, uh Lee Zelden
is very good on the Second Amendment. I
don't think there's a concern when it
comes to that. Okay. But again, we want
someone at the Department of Justice
that will understand the issues and
stand up and fight for the Second
Amendment and recognize and have the
fortitude, if you will, to stop deep
state careeristers from taking dumb
positions against Second Amendment
organizations across this country, which
in my view they've been doing in many
instances. We don't have to recount them
now. We can do it in a separate video.
And the last idea I have, and I don't
think anybody else has connected the
dots. Maybe I'm the only one. Let me
know what you think of this. And here's
a crazy idea, but maybe not so crazy. If
Justice Clarence Thomas, who I love, and
uh Justice Samo, who we love, if one or
both of them were to retire this year at
the end of the Supreme Court term, I
don't know if that's going to happen. I
have no inside knowledge. I have no
idea. Okay. But if one of them wanted to
retire now and be replaced before the
midterms, I don't know. Attorney General
Clarence Thomas, Attorney General Samuel
Leto would probably be good on all the
issues, including uh our Second
Amendment rights in particular. But
again, just an idea throwing it out
there for all you guys in social media
and whatnot to chat about. And the last
thing I want to make and this is very
important. Okay, star this point. Okay,
everybody you recommend has to be
nominated by the president of the United
States, right? Donald Trump, but most
importantly has to be confirmed by the
Senate. Okay, the Republican majority in
the US Senate today is a Republican
majority, but it's not a MAGA majority.
It's not a super conservative majority.
We have Lisa Macowski who's terrible
from Alaska who's technically a
Republican. We know no Democrat will
vote to support any uh nominee by
President Trump unless it's a foregone
conclusion that they're going to get
confirmed. We have Susan Collins who is
a Republican from Maine and is actually
pretty good on these kinds of issues,
but still she's up for a tough
re-election fight. You don't know if
Susan Collins is going to have to vote
against Donald Trump to make sure she
wins in the fall. From a strategic point
of view, I could see that happening. So,
you got Marcowsky and Susan Collins, and
then you've got, you know, uh, retiring
Senator Tom Tillis of North Carolina,
who now that he's basically been forced
out by his anti-Trumpism, he is, you
know, speaking out against Trump more
and more. He might want to leave um, you
know, his job in the Senate and retire
by doing something to thumb his nose at
President Trump's nomination. I'm not
saying that will happen. It's a
possibility. And of course, we wake up
one day and Ken Paxton has defeated John
Cornin. Who knows what John Cornin might
do out of spite to President Trump in
terms of whether or not he would vote to
confirm someone that Donald Trump
nominated. And of course, we can also
throw out the possibility, although I
think this is my last kind of crazy
idea. It's just a crazy idea. I'm not
endorsing these things. I'm flagging it
for you all to talk about and think
about because I'm not in a position to
vet people. I I don't have the inside
information. I'm not on the transition
team like I was in the past. I don't
have that inside information about, you
know, girlfriends or boyfriends or
problems or family member, all the
things that you have to sometimes
consider in these sort of complex
discretionary decisions by the
president. I don't have access to any of
that stuff. So, I'm just throwing ideas
out there and spitballing a little bit,
but the only other observation would be,
wouldn't it be very interesting, and my
friends in Texas may get mad about this,
but I'm not recommending it. I'm just
throwing it out there. It would be kind
of an interesting situation um if you
could cut a deal. I'm not saying I would
love the deal. I'm just throwing it out
there. Uh where Ken Paxton became the
next attorney general of the United
States and John Cornin was then endorsed
to be the next senator, the ongoing
senator from Texas. And then you give
Ken Paxton the attorney general sought
for the United States of America and
John Cornin gets another six years in
the Senate. I'm not saying I love that
idea. I'm just putting out there as
something for all of you guys in the
know to consider. And I'm sure there's
many other people uh that can be
considered. But remember, no matter
whose name you flag, the president has
to approve the person, has to nominate
the person, and most importantly, the
United States Senate has to confirm that
person. And that's why you always have
to remember and this is one of the
reasons why I did not love the idea of
getting rid of Attorney General Pam
Bonnie is because I looked down the
chessboard and realize that there will
be another confirmation fight in the
Senate and there is no guarantee we will
get someone better than Attorney General
Pam Bonnie. Okay folks, there you have
it. Hope you enjoyed today's episode.
Make sure you follow me over there on
X4boxes Diner. Don't forget to subscribe
both the YouTube and the Rumble and I'll
talk to all of you again real soon here
at the Forboxes Diner.
Orders up. Table 2 A.